coordination's coming up I know right
yeah my girl's going to be singing
that's fun I'm not going to make it
there sadly but but she's representing
which is cool that's cool I mean you got
to be like yeah it's cool she does those
big historical things it's wonderful she
did the she said to the president too
you know she does that I mean but listen
who's left I know maybe the pope yeah
um so yeah it's it's exciting
Gran Turismo yeah I really did not know
much about this movie and now I feel
like it looks so good tell me about I
mean look I played this game on
PlayStation when I was a kid I was like
how are they gonna adapt this into a
movie what do you think it is that makes
this movie so special and a good kind of
adaptation yeah great question you know
I'm I I didn't play the game so I can't
speak to that but I know that hundreds
of millions of people did and I'm always
curious as to how they translate a game
into a movie but fortunately uh with
this movie we have uh the true story of
Jan martinborough who was a young kid
from Wales who was so good
in the simulator they're actually uh
Danny my character who was based on a
true life marketing executive at Nissan
came up with this idea of taking Gamers
and putting them into cars because they
were so good in the simulator he was
like what about if we took Gamers put
them in real cars and stuck them on a
track and see what happens kind of thing
he was a mad dreamer of an is as an idea
and
it kind of worked and yeah and raced and
he then to this day races and he Podium
that Le Mans and it's so the story is
whilst um we have that great you know
Gran Turismo title it's based very much
in in the true uh real life story of Jan
Martin bro who's you know played by
Archie fantastically do you ever think
about like
what if you were really good at
something and you just never know
because you never did it like what if
I'm the best disc golfer in the entire
world and I just don't know I know I'm
always like I think that's part of the
dream machine that we have with this
this movie which I think could play so
well in the theaters I mean I just saw
the trailer for the first time here
which was fantastic but essentially you
know that idea that any kid can hang on
to like wait I could maybe become that
good if I get that good and my
dedication is enough and I could
actually take it from my home my living
room my bedroom wherever you play into a
real car I mean it's kind of like the
Ultimate Dream right for any young kid
who's out there looking to play so I
think um that's the realization part of
the realization with a lot of twists and
turns along the way because it wasn't
straightforward and actually Anne's uh
you know true life story is is is full
of uh you know twists and turns as life
is so it's it's cool is there a game
you're really good at like video game
board game anything like that I wish I
could say I played games I'm not really
I'm like I play chess so I like chess
that doesn't count though does it it
could be you could be me and chess I'm
really bad at chess uh and it's been a
minute actually I'm not saying how many
girls I'm just saying I'm playing and
again
um but uh no not a gamer sorry
okay
everybody games
to Gran Turismo since because I do like
to go very fast and I feel like the
simulation is so real that you can kind
of take it yeah and I think that's
probably VR stuff but when the Press
store comes around they talk about the
game you'll be like yeah I know yeah
like yeah that's me I got it all the
time now I have one in my backyard and
I'm doing it in my my
all right did you get behind the wheel
at all hey yeah yeah I have I did I did
get more in the wheel yeah how was that
it's awesome those those cars are
insanely powerful and uh and it's uh
it's like hang on to your hang on to
your helmet kind of kind of feelings you
know it's like butterflies it's good you
know April Fool's Day was recently and I
actually almost fell for one about you
it said Orlando Bloom returning to
Middle Earth and I was like oh my God
and I clicked on it and then it was like
April fools oh my God why am I on the
internet today
yeah it's being done really well right
now I can't see where uh where leggy
fits in anymore but it was a good one
did you watch ranks of power I actually
enjoyed it yeah I thought they did a
great job you know it's what I was I was
just really it was just refreshing to be
reminded of Tolkien in the world that
Tolkien created you know I mean I think
there's a reason why the books have been
famously so successful and that our
movies were also wonderfully successful
and that the show is doing great things
too because it sort of takes an audience
into that world and that world of
Tolkien and that brain which is like way
you know way ahead of his time yeah
where to next where are you going
um I'm actually going to shoot a movie
uh back in my uh my own neck of the
woods so yeah it's gonna be cool that's
awesome yes thank you
[Music]